hi i'm rebecca friesenhoff from marvel's
hero project marvel's hero project is a
docu-series that highlights 20 kids
doing amazing things in their
communities and i was so honored to be a
part of it it's so important for kids
like me to be lifted up on platforms
like this because
representation matters and other trans
kids deserve to see people like them in
their media it was actually a little
weird to be followed around by a film
crew but i got used to it i really like
the little surprise at the end so you'll
have to watch to figure it out i hope
you enjoy my episode of marvel's hero
project and you can watch all the other
episodes on disney plus happy pride
at marvel our stories and our
superheroes are inspired by real life
heroes
so the editors of some of our best known
comics have come together to work on a
special project to find and tell the
stories of kids doing the extraordinary
helping communities near and far and
changing the world
these are the kids who will inspire our
stories for years to come i heard
stories of people being bullied in
school i was heartbroken i needed to
stand up for this by telling my story
minds are changed rebecca is already a
hero now we bring her story to the world
with the surprise of a lifetime making
her into a marvel superhero immortalized
in her very own comic as a member of
marvel's hero project
[Music]
their everyday kids
who have accomplished the amazing
now their true stories
[Music]
will reveal the heroes
that live among us
this is marvel's hero project
rebecca is the kind of kid we wanted to
bring a spotlight on and bring her into
the marvel universe because i think we
need her yeah
in our comics we talk all the time about
the journey that our heroes have been on
and sort of the process of them becoming
a hero and it makes me excited when i
think about rebecca to become this
staunch advocate for lgbtq rights and a
kid who puts herself uh in front of
issues to stand for other people a big
part of every hero's journey is also the
support system they have the family we
have peter in out may or the richards
family and the support that that
rebecca's family has given her it's just
such a heartwarming story right i keep
thinking about kamala khan
this young hero who really tried to
figure out who she is
and struggled with that and and
eventually embraced it and i feel like
rebecca did the exact same thing she
embraced who she was became empowered by
it and now her story is one about
passing that on to others she just has
found like
exactly who she
knows she is and she's using that
to like bring more acceptance to the
world which is a beautiful thing to do
that's really an important message that
we have to share with the next
generation for kids for people of all
different kinds of backgrounds and and
rebecca is such a powerful young person
to be able to do that
when i scored my first goal it was
amazing i was
so excited
i scored the goal that won
[Music]
it was zero zero and then
once i scored
i changed what happened
it was just like when i'm speaking
all these people are hearing me
and their minds are being changed by
one little voice
so what are you going to do with ms eve
today probably both the hammock and the
lira oh nice yeah
i first started dancing
four years ago
i was
eight i think yeah i was eight or nine
all right
we'll see you later
bye bye
you have to use your strength to make
yourself do this thing that
is really hard three four that was so
good rebecca
[Music]
when i was little i was
very
energetic i loved running outside
i also loved the color pink and all
things that are typically girly
but as i got older it got harder to wear
pink things
people were like confused like that's
not what a boy should be wearing
[Music]
when rebecca was born everyone thought
she was a boy she was assigned male at
birth and we assumed that for many years
that she was a boy
and by three or four kids at school were
saying why are you wearing girl stuff or
why are you doing that that's for girls
or pink is a girl color
we had told rebecca then you know you
can be whoever you are you can be
whatever kind of boy you are you can
wear whatever color you want
she had gone to a faith-based program
for the arts and they put her in a
different group because none of the
parents wanted her in their kids group
anymore
i was pretty sad because it's hard to be
different from everyone else and to
not be accepted
around seven and a half the anxiety
became crippling and depression came
along for the ride
no one prepares you for a seven and a
half year old who wants to die
[Music]
you do everything you can for your kids
and when they feel like
they're too much or the world's too much
truth whatever it is
that breaks your heart
really at the
root of all the
trouble she was having
was an identity
who she was wasn't who she was being
and that needed to change
[Music]
i first heard and saw the word
transgender when i was eight years old
me and my mom were looking for
gender-neutral swimsuits
we sat down at my computer and we
googled gender non-conforming swimsuits
we didn't find a lot but all these lgbt
links came up
and i said do you know what these
letters mean she said no i don't know
what lgbt means and so i went through
the acronym with her and when i got to
the t i explained what transgender was
and it was like a light bulb went off in
her head
[Music]
t was a big revelation a big epiphany
for rebecca
that transgender
is a thing and that this is a thing that
might describe me
it felt amazing to know that i didn't
have to pretend to be something or
someone that i wasn't
so i started using she her pronouns and
i started to keep my hair growing longer
i was really really happy because
i was
more me
my mom she says that um god does not
make mistakes
so as i transitioned she just kept
reminding me that
the gospel rebecca's always had a lot of
joy
but before i think she saved the joy for
the places that she was most comfortable
after her transition
that joy just kind of spilled out all
over the place
this scripture has been fulfilled in
your presence after her transition it
was really kind of like a different
person
she was much more outgoing and
um i'm gonna say fun
i see a happy child
a happy girl god's creation
simply put
it's hard to work through the emotional
pieces of it
the scariness the sense of loss the
worry about what else is this going to
mean those were hard conversations
it was never a hard conversation
do we do this
that's just not who we
are me and my mom both um
advocate
advocate
when the federal administration
rescinded the guidelines for trans
students in schools garden state
equality came together to say we need
new jersey guidelines
they assembled a rally in jersey city so
i reached out and just said hey if you
need a mom as a speaker let me know and
they responded and said yeah you and
rebecca can speak just trying to be
themselves and i was like oh um oh okay
hi my name is rebecca i am a transgender
girl i've been living as myself since i
was 8 years old and now i am 10.
[Applause]
it was kind of nerve-wracking because
you know it was my first time speaking
there yeah and speaking anywhere
speaking anywhere
every transgender kid deserves the
support i get and that's why i'm here
holy moly she was just a natural
all these people were impressed by her
bravery and the clarity of this is who i
am and i deserve a safe school
suddenly people cared and wanted to hear
your voice they wanted to hear what i
had to say on the matter of
me being me
to hear other people's stories who they
weren't supported by their family or
community that was sad
it's crazy that somebody's family
wouldn't support them
a lot of the other stories that were
shared were ones of struggle
kids whose schools weren't safe or
adults who when they came out faced a
lot of challenges i grew up in a world
where transgender wasn't on anybody's
lips and i know what it's like to live
in the wrong body for well over 55 years
all those friends doing to my transition
i lost friends because i wanted to turn
myself into the man i'm supposed to be
i heard stories of people being bullied
in school and having their faith be in
the way of their transition
and
i was heartbroken
i decided that i needed to keep speaking
for the people who need the message of
hope
and acceptance i think she realized the
power she was holding it was
what i was meant to do they're just
being who they are we want to go to
school learn and just be a kid trans
kids out there do not be afraid we will
continue to stand on the shoulders of
the fierce advocates who came before us
you are brave you are beautiful you are
strong and you are not alone
[Applause]
as my voice became more and more heard
i felt that i could make a bigger and
bigger impact on the world
i've learned that by being who god has
called me to be and by telling my story
hearts and minds are changed
i can change the world
[Applause]
morning chicky
the world isn't quite ready for her
i mean it's getting closer and she's
working really hard to make it better
but the world isn't where we need it to
be for rebecca to have the life she
deserves
i worry about who's gonna know and how
they're gonna react
i worry
that someone's gonna not understand who
she hasn't hurt her
but also there's a lot of inspiration in
a young child getting up there and
knowing they can make a difference
okay
my name is rebecca breezaha from vernon
new jersey and i am speaking in support
of assembly bill one three three five
all right you ready yeah do some hair i
love school and i have great friends
there
i also happen to be transgender
i love learning about the history of our
country in school
i've learned about immigrants and the
great migration
brave soldiers and founding fathers
i've learned about all this but i've
never seen myself in the history they
are teaching
i wish my school was teaching me and my
peers about things like harvey milk and
the pride flag marsha p johnson and the
stonewall riots
this is about so much more than just a
history lesson
it's about being seen and valued as part
of the school community
this bill gives me hope that my
classmates will someday learn about how
lgbtq people have helped move our
country forward
and whatever impact i may make on the
world
might be included in history classes too
thank you
rebecca
thank you very much for what you're
doing and i vote yes
[Music]
i love being an activist because
it can be a little scary to talk about
how i was not
happy before i was
who i am today
the statistics are terrifying
the biggest one for parents of trans
kids and we were faced with it right
away is that 41 of transgender people
attempt suicide at some point in their
life
41
and what we know is that support is the
single most mitigating factor in that
hello everybody
i'm so happy that you're here and i'm
very excited to meet you
[Music]
rebecca's been able to own that being
trans isn't something bad
it's not a secret to hide this is a
beautiful amazing part of your identity
and she's been able to share that and
can do great things with it yeah
there was a lot of cool stations there
were school council meetings where
people would argue about
me going to these bathrooms and it
really hurt sorry
it's very nice to be with other kids who
know what i'm going through especially
what do you guys do for bathing suits in
the summer i do shorts and like
yeah t-shirts
even though we share like all the good
things we might also
have to share the bad things because
it's not always perfect
there are some people that don't
understand trans people at all like
why'd you get mad when the sub said your
name wrong like geez it's not the big
idea but like it is a big deal so what's
your name i am lucas or a lunar because
i'm thinking about transitioning during
april vacation
we use rebecca's story to even teach my
husband
and lucas's older sister it helps
significantly for people to learn about
lucas through rebecca
oh yeah i was definitely inspired a lot
she seems very brave
this is
who i am
i'm sorry i'm getting emotion
[Music]
continue doing what you're doing you're
a positive influence
and i just want you to know that i
support you completely
you know that right
be yourself
you are perfect
you are whole and holy
[Music]
when we talk about issues you forget
that there's people behind them
and then cute little rebecca shows up
and it's just like this is me this is my
life and oh it's not so scary
people wanted to listen to me and it was
kind of
odd because i know that kids are always
looked over
but voices of kids like me
make a big impact and
it feels
really good to know that i'm helping a
lot of people
one of the things rebecca hears a lot is
that when people see her out there it
gives them courage to be themselves and
i think when she hears that it gives her
a sense of her own power and how she can
use that for other people
other kids see her story and say oh
there's someone like me i'm not alone
we're not scary i'm just me i'm
a proud 12 year old girl
[Music]
i think that
i am helping others and i want to
continue
[Music]
rebecca's story is so special and moving
and a lot of it's because this idea that
you can change the world by being you it
goes to the heart of so many of the
superhero stories that we tell and she's
taking that
that confidence in herself and bringing
it to other people to inspire you know
love and confidence in them as well so
much of her advocacy is about giving
other kids the confidence and and hope
that that she's found um through her
support systems and through her own
bravery and even beyond the super
heroics of it all of who who she is
finding the details
about her that we could put into the
story of the hair yeah her hair she's
got some lovely pink hair like she's so
fashionable so i hope that we lived up
to that a little bit yeah got some big
surprises planned for her yeah yeah out
in new jersey where they just you know
the legislation that she was advocating
for just got passed yeah so uh the
legislation will go into effect in in
2021 and essentially what it means is
that schools in new jersey will now
include lgbtq history in their
curriculum in the meantime what rebecca
is doing is doing a book drive to gather
books on that subject for schools and
libraries so we've got the one lgbtq
book she doesn't have in the book drive
we're gonna surprise her with the first
issue of the mighty rebecca number one
yes and one of the people participating
in the reveal is one of her her heroes a
trans activist named jazz jennings she's
done so much for others we really want
to give her something that's hers
hello
i read this one why did you bring these
books to your book
thank you you're welcome
how are you doing today thank you for
donating these
[Music]
hi rebecca it's jazz
hello
i wanted to tell you that i am so so
incredibly proud of you and all of the
incredible work that you do for the
trans community you are making a
difference and changing hearts and minds
so you should be so proud of yourself i
know i'm proud of you thank you
before i go there's one more surprise
waiting for you in the back so i hope
you enjoy it i'm really glad that we got
to talk
yeah i was i'm really glad too okay well
enjoy the surprise and reach out to me
whenever you need to okay okay bye
she just told me that there was a
surprise in the back yeah should we go
i guess i think so
oh my gosh
dear rebecca
right now you are surrounded by your
loved ones
those who have supported you in
difficult times and who have given you
the courage to be the person you are
you do the same for others
your bravery determination and
compassion shine through in everything
you do
standing up for yourself and other
transgender kids
you continue to change the world around
you into a more accepting place you
stand for everything that makes a marvel
superhero great
from the confidence and strength of
captain marvel to the bravery of black
widow
that's why we're making you an official
member of a team of heroes just like you
a remarkable group of young people whose
passion and advocacy fill us with all
welcome to the marvel hero project
there's a box in front of you
you got it got it okay okay
oh my
open the box
take out the jacket
it's a symbol of your status on the
marvel team we hope you wear it with
pride
oh my gosh
[Music]
looking good yeah do you like it yeah
okay
also to show how much we admire
everything you've done we are making a
donation in your honor to an
organization that supports the lgbtq
community in the amount of ten thousand
dollars
[Music]
we have one more surprise for you it's
an instant collector's item a marvel
comic book inspired by and all about you
we hope you see yourself in these pages
the same way we at the mighty marvel
bullpen do as a real life superhero
welcome to the marvel hero project
rebecca your friends at marvel
whoa
in the box i found this jacket
and a comic book
of
me the marvel hero hero project
featuring the mighty rebecca
i really like that
i think i can fix this fix what the
window or the fact that people just seem
to hate us just because of who we are my
favorite part is this part because it
shows that lgbtq kids are the same as
other kids
i like the new sign you belong here
she changed it to say you belong here
well i guess i changed
i like the picture where she's working
with her tongue out
because it looks just it looks just like
you
it's really neat to
kind of watch rebecca look at that and
know that there's
something that makes her a part of
a small group of people you know that
are doing great things to change the
world
i think it's so important to have marvel
say that she's a kid like any other to
tell her story to think of all the kids
that will see this and see themselves in
her is really exciting we'll make it
there someday i promise as long as we
keep moving forward together i'm really
proud to represent the lgbtq community
in the comic book and
i think it's really important for other
lgbtq youth to see the role model in
their community
[Music]
[Music]
you